[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir de
recevoir John artiste une musicienne
elle s'appelle Garance tout court elle
est Yves linoise et elle vient nous
présenter son nouvel EP et nous parler
d'un futur concert Garance tout court
bonjour bonjour merci de me recevoir
merci d'être là vous allez bien très
bien pas trop chaud non ça va super
alors on va vous découvrir vous avez un
univers bien à vous c'est ça qui est
intéressant heureusement et on va moi
j'aimerais savoir depuis quand vous fait
de la musique depuis toute petite j'ai
commencé le piano à 6 ans et ensuite je
suis rentrée en horaire aménagé au
Centre de Musique Baroque de Versailles
dans une chorale mais 8 ans je crois
maintenant donc depuis toujours et
c'était votre volonté ou c'est vos
parents qui vous ont poussé le piano
c'était ma en fait petite je parlais pas
j'étais très introvertie je faisais que
de chanter mais je parlais pas et puis
très rapidement j'ai voulu faire du
piano donc là je les ai un peu harcelés
il préférait que je fasse de la guitare
ou un instrument qui coûte un peu moins
cher et il dit non piano et puis ensuite
les classeurs aménagers là c'était plus
fallait soit que je saute une classe et
j'avais pas envie parce que j'avais
qu'une seule amie j'avais pas envie
d'être avec les plus grands et du coup
du coup au lieu de sauter une classe ils
m'ont mis en horreur aménagé pour que
les disciplines soient un peu plus
je sais pas comment dire
plus simple pour vous et exactement et
du coup dans la dans la musique ça
paraissait cohérent d'accord et là vous
jouez du piano et le chant alors c'est
venu quand bah justement dans cette
chorale quel centre de musique barque de
Versailles donc à partir de 9 ans ça
c'est un nom cette chorale oui la
maîtrise
OK et alors cette cette votre côté
professionnel chanteuse vous êtes
interprète
compositrice autrice productrice vous
faites tout en gros quoi oui voilà et en
tant que professionnel ça fait combien
de temps ça je me suis parce que j'ai
complètement arrêté la musique à
l'adolescence
et puis j'ai repris à l'âge de mes 20
ans et j'ai envie là vraiment depuis
trois quatre ans d'accord voilà ok et
vous avez donc sorti plusieurs morceaux
différents et là on va parler de votre
nouvelle EP qui s'appelle Mel pommeN
alors qui est Melpomène alors Mel pommeN
c'est initialement la muse du champ et
de l'harmonie musicale et lorsqu'elle
est associée à Dionysos elle devient la
muse de la tragédie d'accord et j'ai vu
aussi que ces servantes étaient la
terreur c'est suivante pardon la terreur
et la pitié donc ça c'est le titre c'est
le nom de votre votre bébé qui compose
de fait 7 morceaux voilà et comment vous
définissez votre votre style de musique
j'ai toujours beaucoup de mal pour moi
je fais de la pop
du moins j'ai la j'ai l'impression de la
pop française après la pop c'est très
vaste
du coup j'imagine que je suis
il y a mes influences j'ai aussi fait
j'ai fait donc de la musique baroque et
j'ai fait aussi du jazz donc peut-être
qu'il y a un peu des influences à
l'intérieur et
j'imagine que j'explore plusieurs
sonorités bon du coup je dis pop mais
j'ai toujours un peu de mal
dans deux trois morceaux j'ai noté la
valse à trois teintes et puis et puis je
sais plus lequel
on a une intro qui est vraiment lyrique
symphonique et on se dit bah il y a le
baroque qui sommeille encore en vous
enfin qui sommeille ou pas justement
mais mais qui est encore présent quoi
ça habite encore votre musique et alors
dites-moi c'est vous qui écrivez les
paroles oui voilà et alors ces paroles
elles sont elles sont quand même assez
engagées vous ne parlez pas pour ne rien
dire
NON NON bah ça va avec qui je suis dans
la vie j'imagine
je suis assez engagée et en l'occurrence
beaucoup pour la cause féministe et je
pense être quelqu'un d'assez souvent
frontal et
même parfois un petit peu provocante je
crois et du coup je pense que que dans
mes textes ça peut ça correspond parce
que vous êtes voilà et moi je vous
propose qu'on écoute un extrait de d'un
de des morceaux de votre nouvelle EP
avec plaisir
est-ce que tu as déjà pris pour que la
prochaine vie soit la bonne pour que
cette fois-ci tu t'incarnes en homme en
as-tu déjà tellement voulu à ce corps
qu'elle tient jusqu'à en vomir jusqu'à
crever de faim est-ce que tu as déjà
tant voulu que ce soit les hommes qui se
battent pour toi parce que quand c'est
les femmes qui font on parle que de
leurs poils sous les bras tu as voulu
croire on se met que de changer les
idées qui changent et des idiots passés
et puis qui les a dépassés
[Musique]
j'ai mal alors que j'ai mal aux orgas
il y en a qui s'en sortent mal
voilà alors ça s'appelle Mego alors moi
quand je l'ai écouté comme je suis un
petit peu j'ai l'âge que j'ai bref il y
a des mots que qui m'ont échappé alors
moi j'entendais orgueil et organe mon
gogo c'était ça la chanson mais non le
titre c'est ça veut dire autre chose
mégot oui alors expliquez-moi s'il vous
plaît donc Go c'est ces femmes en fait
c'est meuf donc mes gosses et mes gosses
ça peut être mais mes sœurs mais mes
femmes mes copines d'accord toutes les
femmes voilà et alors ça
ça comment dire ça sent un peu le levécu
oui cette chanson vous avez
un truc particulier parce que c'est
on peut s'en rentrer dans le vif du
sujet je pense que que je fais partie de
toute façon les chiffres sont là on est
beaucoup à avoir vécu des violences
sexuelles donc
voilà voilà ça ressort aussi en chanson
et puis vous associer vos gaufres en
fait c'est comme enfin je pensais tout à
l'heure c'est comme un garçon qui dit
mon frère voilà tout à fait et je pense
que la chanson ça avait cette volonté là
de parfois justement quand on a une
douleur qu'on peut penser finalement
personnelle face à quelque chose un
drame qu'on a vécu on la ressent dès
lors qu'on voit que qu'elle arrive en
fait un peu partout autour de nous et
que elle est en fait c'est des violences
qui sont presque systémiques et souvent
on se reprend une claque quand on voit
ça autour de nous et
après il y a quelque chose en même temps
parfois d'assez je vais pas dire que ça
guérit mais la sororité que moi j'ai pu
expérimenter dans le milieu militant et
elle est aussi parfois quand on se rend
compte que notre douleur c'est pas que
nous mais que en fait c'est quelque
chose qui existe
on a aussi un certain soutien
vous porte ça vous aide peut-être c'est
un peu moins lourd oui en tout cas quand
j'ai écrit la chanson
le refrain je trouvais important
parfois de se battre pour les autres
ça permet
je me perds un peu dans ce que je dis
parce que dans votre dans cette chanson
un moment vous écrivez celle qui renonce
celle qui s'éteint donc là vous êtes un
peu leur porte-parole quoi vous vous
sentez pour elle aussi c'est qui qui
comme vous contrairement à vous ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer ou non pas la
force et qui et donc vous prenez la
parole aussi pour ces Go là ouais ouais
et j'imagine que j'ai souvent eu
moi-même pas la force de m'exprimer et
que et que j'ai aimé quand d'autres
s'exprimer à ma place et voilà
pas forcément et ça dépend comment se
passent les choses etc et moi j'ai il y
a une autre chanson qui est très forte
je trouve un autre morceau qui s'appelle
alors la valse à trois temps alors moi
j'apprends des mots grâce à vous c'est
super alors top je me suis dit bon la
valse à trois temps d'accord mais alors
tu as un peu c'est quoi donc c'est quoi
le verlan de d'accord
d'accord et donc c'est assez
mélancolique cette chanson et
comment dire
qu'est-ce que vous nous dites là alors
là je parle du destin de trois femmes la
première ça peut être moi comme ça peut
être n'importe
quelle femme on sait pas trop la
deuxième c'est Eve et la troisième c'est
Vanessa Campos et donc la première
finalement est quelqu'un qui a pu se
faire insulter ou s'auto insulter de
honte qui croient être dans une
répétition de schéma de violence la
deuxième c'est Eve donc c'est la grande
la grande coupable celle à cause de qui
on paye tous les péchés donc c'est aussi
un peu une et la troisième c'est
une vraie c'est une vraie
prostituée Vanessa compose qui s'est
fait assassiner et ça permet finalement
cette chanson de dire on est sans arrêt
en fait en train d'insulter les
mais les femmes de et en fait plus
ce n'est pas une insulte parce que c'est
un métier et qui en l'occurrence est
très dangereux et très dangereux c'est
une certaine catégorie bien sûr
et donc voilà d'accord et en arrière
fond de ce morceau on entend un extrait
d'une émission télévisée qui date de
quand vous vous souvenez vous de la date
de ce
on parle de Gainsbourg on parle de
Gainsbourg
j'imagine
donc
en fait c'est Gainsbourg qui est sur un
même le même plateau que Catherine
Ringer donc des Rita Mitsouko qui n'est
pas encore connue donc facile elle est
elle est interviewée et je me suis
appuyée exactement de l'extrait mais
elle dit elle se dit racontez-nous en
fait elle
il commence à l'embêter et à l'insulter
parce que elle a fait du porno oui mais
elle le dit elle elle assume qu'elle a
dit en haut et lui dit qu'elle est
dégueulasse il lui parle très mal et
puis il lui dit qu'elle est une et
elle elle lui répond c'est pas la même
chose c'est pas le même métier et de
manière je trouve très courageuse
c'est-à-dire de déjà d'assumer elle le
métier qu'elle a pu avoir et de dire il
y en a un autre métier et c'est un
métier et puis voilà et à l'époque ce
cet extrait de d'émission ne choque pas
plus que ça parce que ça fait partie du
personnage Gainsbourg qui qui traite de
même de je crois et à fond
il va à fond c'est un peu facile aussi
bon elle se défendre
et aujourd'hui vous croyez qu'on
pourrait
j'imagine qu'on a un petit peu avancé et
que et que le personnage de Gainsbourg
ferait beaucoup plus polémique
aujourd'hui on l'idole à très sans doute
un peu moins après je pense que le
chemin est long avant qu'on arrête
d'idolâtrer des personnages misogynes et
en l'occurrence que les les soient
reconnus et en sécurité ça on en est
vraiment très très loin OK et alors
dites-moi
qu'est-ce que je voulais vous demander
oui alors votre disque c'est c'est
disque
votre EP voilà de cette morceau c'est on
peut caractériser comment c'est un
manifeste c'est un coup de poing c'est
ah là là une révolte
alors moi si je l'ai appelé malpoman
c'est parce que je l'ai pensé comme une
tragédie je fais aussi du théâtre et
donc c'était important pour moi de
l'envisager comme ça et du coup
pour moi chaque morceau est en soi
aborde des thèmes tragiques en tout cas
dans ma perception au moment où je les
écris donc des choses qui ne tombent
dessus et on y peut rien c'est-à-dire le
viol le fait d'être femme les problèmes
de santé etc et en même temps le P euh
en tant que tel avec cette morceaux et
aussi un peu penser comme comme une
tragédie et comme
là pour le coup une histoire un peu
personnelle et comment on pourrait la
raconter si c'était une pièce de théâtre
tragique d'accord voilà et vous auriez
imaginé chanter autre chose les petits
oiseaux les fleurs et non non c'est pour
ça que ça a été long le travail de cette
paix c'est que les premières rencontres
que que j'ai faites avant de en fait moi
me former à la à la prod et à
l'arrangement et faire mon école de jazz
c'était compliqué je m'associe avec j'ai
rencontré des gens beaucoup des hommes
qui voulaient que je fasse ça aimer toi
en plus
et puis c'est plus agréable sur scène
aussi d'avoir des valeurs
sur scène c'est bientôt quand même le 16
septembre vous aurez votre premier grand
concert là ça va être un gros gros
concert donc au Palais des Congrès de
Versailles et
ce qui est génial c'est déjà il y a
symboliquement je retourne à Versailles
et en fait je vais vu que c'est une
grosse salle j'ai écrit des arrangements
j'ai vu le truc un peu plus en grand que
les autres concerts que j'ai pu faire
auparavant et mes anciens camarades de
chorale de la maîtrise du coup ont
accepté de venir j'ai écrit des
partitions pour chorales donc il va y
avoir très fort je pense et dites-moi il
y a qui sur scène alors il y aura qui
alors il y aura donc mes musiciennes
donc j'ai une batteuse qui s'appelle
Chloé une bassiste qui s'appelle
Alexandra et une guitariste qui
s'appelle Zoé elles sont géniales SIM il
y aura du coup des anciens camarades de
la pas mal de la maîtrise du Centre de
Musique de Versailles et puis des petits
invités des amis artistes qui viennent
voilà donc on va entendre cette paix et
des morceaux d'avant morceau des
morceaux d'avant des morceaux de demain
qui vont être produits cet été peut-être
exactement parce qu'il faut tenir c'est
un concert c'est long c'est 1h30
il faut le nourrir
voilà bravo pour ce pour cette paix pour
ce ces 7 morceaux forts intéressants et
beau vraiment et bah écoutez Garance
tout court pas très vite merci
merci au revoir à tous merci de nous
avoir suivi à très vite
[Musique]